we have the odds who will win the World
Cup is Landon Donovan here hey Landon
okay hey bud thanks for helping us here
now
Seaton is Seaton has the number one pick
in the draft I want you to analyze our
picks here we have three rounds and but
Seaton is only taking one country
because he said that country will win
the World Cup he will lead us off and
then I want your reaction in a moment of
Seaton O'Connor a snake dropped or it it
sneaks it work yeah snake draft I don't
know I probably will I'll just go Seaton
Paulie
McLovin fritzy and then I'll be fifth
yeah I'll get two picks all right Seaton
O'Connor the country that will win the
World Cup or you face a shower of shame
is doesn't Lane they want to guess okay
Landon you want to go well if it were me
or what you're gonna choose either
you're probably gonna choose like okay
that's fair okay
but but here comment okay but who would
you pick no no I want Seaton I want no
no hold on Landon I once see a pic I
don't want you to help him alright fine
no help a team that I love this year's
Belgium Belgium I like a lot golden
generation they score a lot of goals a
lot of goals okay I think correct me if
I'm wrong but I think scoring goals is
important in this competition it can be
so I would say I like Belgium but it's
way too early and I think they are one
of the two and we'll get to the other
most talented teams but they have yet to
show that they can put it together in a
big tournament so I would have taken
them much later but I do like them okay
Paulie you're ready with your pick I'm
beer bitte one beer please Germany
welcome to my squad Germany is off the
boards there ding-ding-ding McLovin ok
so I saw a video of his teammates
Neymar's teammates breaking eggs on his
head and I'm all in on Brazil they seem
like they're having a lot
of fun coming in loose okay that's
Brazil okay I see you this is what I
would say about Brazil Brazil is the
country that every time the World Cup
comes around everyone's talking about
them for some reason nobody's talking
about Brazil and they're really good so
I think they're as weird as this is to
say there's sort of a dark horse even
though a lot of people don't really
mention them and in the we can win the
World Cup type of a category fritzy I am
going to go with Spain Spain is off the
board another under I think appreciated
this is sort of their last chance of
this golden generation of really really
really good players so I would say there
and just barely in that second tier but
they're absolutely capable of winning it
alright I have two picks here Landon I'm
gonna make one pick and then I'm gonna
ask for a lifeline here since I know
probably less about soccer than anybody
else so I'm gonna go Argentina here take
Argentina off the board now I got ya
okay you didn't like that pick I there's
friends about England Uruguay Portugal
Croatia okay so you didn't like my
Argentina pick
well here's I mean Argentina obviously
they have in my opinion the best player
in the world but they just massively
struggle I would personally love to see
them win because I think Messi deserves
that but they tend to just they tend to
just underperform a little bit in these
terms and if you look at their roster
versus other rosters they're just not in
my opinion not quite as good as some of
the top top team Landon Donovan calls
Leo Messi overrated on the Dan Patrick
so what it felt like okay now do i I
can't buy into England right there's
France no Uruguay Portugal Croatia do I
do the home team Russia France and I'll
tell you why they were my other team who
are Talent well I think they are the
most talented team player for player and
the in the tournament France somehow
always seem to get
their own way and do something stupid
and TBD whether they do that or not but
if they can hold it together they have
talent-wise they have good enough
players to win and I can relate to that
we're usually do something stupid to get
in your own way so France it seems like
the right time for me okay
back down with Fritzi I am going to go
with Portugal Portugal Portugal is off
the board that's a value pick right
there I think that's a value pick they
one thing they are going for them is
they won the euros and theirs as you
know my twins know a team that wins has
that confidence that when you get into
moments women hold on yes it's
interesting about fritzy's pick is that
he went with two teams from the same
group does that affect his status
I mean Portugal and Spain are both in
Group B every you got to get the winner
out of Group B I could pretty much
guarantee yeah baby okay
McLovin yeah let's speed this up I'm
gonna go with my second favorite player
of all time of course my first favorite
player is the American Gold score
everyone loves Clint Dempsey players
[Laughter]
he's got to be known as Kane from now on
because everybody else all the great
ones have one name here like a nice boy
I was joking about Clinton's my favorite
player of course is Alexi Lalas Wow
that's a shot okay Paulie you're next
they have some of the most disturbing
kits in all the sports Croatia welcome
to my team relax okay am i up next well
if everybody goes twice then it's over
okay boy that's it nobody chose Mexico
dude do we want to have one more round
here nobody took or AG why do we okay
let's do it quickly here this has gone
way too long
okay so then that would be Paul goes
again no no I gotta go then to go didn't
it go me Paul and Paul just went oh
we're gonna win oh you're gonna go last
in this round oh wait not the way it
worked no we came back down and I
thought it went to me and then it went
back on guys have five producers there
and you can't figure out how to do this
we need trams okay it should be me and
then back to Paulie no no you went last
okay wait a minute
remember last night you took Argentina
and France back-to-back I was filled and
then it was third second no snake
backing out sneaking back back the other
way back so Paul just went then Paul
would go again oh okay
urgh why um this seems like it's fixed
for me not to do well I don't think I
took care of that for you pal don't
worry about it thank you McLovin
and now McLovin goes make love and go
okay um I don't think anyone's taking
our favorite team yet how about a little
love for this small country of Iceland
Iceland very good odds like 201 fritzy
you're next Costa Rica no shock in the
world wait we're doing a vacation are
they in Group B as well USA has a better
chance all right I got the final pick
here Landon Donovan I can either go
Colombia Russia Poland or meki oh I
probably go Mexico Manti Mexico is in
the same group as Germany Sweden and
South Korea yeah let me ask you guys a
question
I find myself I tweeted this the other
day I find myself rooting for Mexico and
Panama and Costa Rica because they're in
our region
yeah is that like is that sacrilegious
well USA he's not there so it's not
sacrilegious I'm people are like how can
you root for them I don't know I'm gonna
go Russia
well I know I don't I mean that's just a
home course advantage home cord home
pitch home pitch advantage here I think
they might get a friendly caller - yeah
I'm gonna get I might get tweet I might
get a tweet from the president all right
Landon Donovan of course the greatest US
soccer player of all time I got one
single question for you and one single
question alone that's it
why is Team USA not in the World Cup
aside from not qualifying why didn't
they qualify probably a complacency over
the last decade who's to blame for
complacency there's a lot a lot to go
around I think I think everyone's to
blame it was gonna catch up eventually
if you don't do things the right way and
they caught up to us how do we how do we
do well no I'm just curious then I keep
it feels like it's Groundhog Day every
every couple of years that we it feels
like we're going backwards we're not
going forward where's the where is why
you say that well eight years ago we
we're at least in the conversation to
contend now we didn't even qualify yeah
but that's all I mean I don't look at a
World Cup as actually the barometer of
how you're doing because the World Cup
the national team the full team goes
through phases of good players not as
good players good generations etc but
there's no excuse for not qualifying
that's where I get that's where I get
disturb so as far as performance is
going a World Cup I don't judge that I
always say we don't want to win a World
Cup we want to be in a place where we're
contending every time we're talking
about Brazil Spain France Argentina we
talk about them every time because
they're always there because they have
the infrastructure and they do things
the right way that's where we want to
get yeah but I mean we didn't qualify it
it's one thing to be there just on a
consistent basis but not qualifying them
that's well that's why you have coaching
changes here who should who should be
running Team USA
coaching yeah um a bunch of guys you've
never heard of okay are you well I've
heard of you are you one of those guys I
am NOT I've never coached a day in my
life
wait a lot of soccer I'd be a coach
wait was that but that doesn't always
that doesn't translate
so you've officially turned down the
offer to be part of Team USA is that
what you're saying there's no offer I I
made the offer yes I do are you retiring
well you've retired twice so I didn't I
just don't want to be the last one to
know if you're retiring all right well
you talked about soccer more than once a
year on the show you would know man
don't make me get sources here Landon
and it's once every four years that I
talk soccer okay yeah are you gonna play
you're still playing in Mexico I am okay
all right don't get short with me I'm
just you know I'm just asking taking an
interest in your life a little bit I
appreciate that
how's the family they're doing well I
don't know if you remember the days with
- yeah I'm do under two and a half but
it's yeah
it's it's interesting every day as an
adventure that's why you're still
playing soccer correct yes gonna help ya
get out of the house hey when you get to
four kids under the age of seven then
let me know that's fair you know what I
equate it to your vendor New Orleans
Mardi Gras yeah you know how they you
know how at like 3:00 in the morning
after everyone finally or whatever time
everyone finally goes home and they come
out with the big hoses and they just
spray everything into the sewer yeah
that's how like that's how I feel my
house is like after like ATM you go any
clean up everything
like 7:00 a.m. it starts again you're
gonna play to your 50 now hey good to
catch up with you thanks for joining us
we'll check in with you during the World
Cup if that's okay
all right guys that's Landon Donovan for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]